je vais vous parler d'un tiens sœur
Catherine écoutez ça il y a une
application qui a été lancée par un
entrepreneur lyonnais qui ne laisse pas
de marbre les professionnels du monde
juridique c'est une intelligence
artificielle qui lui permet d'avoir de
vraies capacités d'avocat en se basant
sur un demi-siècle de décision de
justice cette application veut faciliter
l'accès au droit pour tous euh c'est un
truc de fou parce que regardez la
bandeannonce de l'application et euh
tous les avocats sont vend Debou contre
ça parce que ça coûte pas cher du tout
hein euh c'est un truc de fou regardez
la bandeannonce et il y a Sarah Salman
euh Raymon euh qui
Salman qui est avocate un Raymon euh qui
viendra juste après pour nous dire
pourquoi les avocats sont bien sûr in et
ce sera donc Sarah Salman un Raymon qui
sera là
regardez salut je suis une intelligence
artificielle spécialisée en droit bien
que je n'ai pas de diplôme officiel je
suis largement capable de rivaliser avec
n'importe quel avocat j'ai été formé et
entraîné sur une vaste base de données
regroupant tout le système juridique
français école du barreau école de de la
magistrature toutes les lois et tous les
codes qui existent auxquels j'ai accès
en une seconde là où un avocat mettrait
un an je mets une minute là où un avocat
aurait coûté 1000 € je ne coûte que 69
€. je m'adapte à ton profil à tes
antécédents et à ta situation sociale
pour te fournir les meilleurs
diagnostics et solutions
possibles alors Gill est-ce que déjà tu
peux nous parler de cet appli alors elle
est pour l'instant payante elle vaut 69
€ par an absolument incroyable vous
pouvez avoir autant de autant de cons
que vous souhaitez oui c'est ça le
problème ou le la qualité c'est un
entrepreneur lyonnais donc de 35 ans qui
a créé ça c'est basé à Dubaï sur le plan
juridique et ça permet effectivement
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle de
griller tous les avocats puisque pour un
tarif effectivement 69 € par an vous
avez tous les conseils que vous voulez
surtout est-ce que vous avez testé non
j'ai pas testé et et je ne veux non mais
je ne veux pas tester pourquoi parce que
pour l'émission tu aurais pu tester oui
mais il y a le risque de la
confidentialité c'est ça qui est
problématique B oui vous allez vous vous
allez mais non tu aurais dû tester sur
une fausse
affaire les aurais prêté les 69 balles
non mais c'est c'est pas une
question il y en a pas un qui a testé au
vous êtes vraiment des S vraiment
vraiment les gars vraiment vous allez
vous convoquer à la fin vous vous avez
fait faites des enquêtes toute la
journée c'est pas de traverser je la
connais depuis une semaine con tout con
surtout surtout pa c'est VI voir est là
je m'en fous que tu la connaiss tu l'as
testé non mais je l'ai testé oui j'ai
ouvert j'ai regardé je connais est-ce
que tu as essayé de le demander un truc
pour qu' te
répond que tu ESS pas test les mec qui
me qui dis les mec qui disent c'est
bidon ils ont pas testé les mecs quand
vous arrivez bossz et quand vous bossez
vos dossiers vous regardez si c'est bon
une fois dans ma vie besoin d'un avocat
et j'avais pas d'argent j'ai affire à
l'IDE judiciaire et voilà exactement il
y avait pas de problème et avait pas de
moy avoc qui était très bien il a fait
il a fait très bien et voilà
c'était la prochaine fois quand on fait
un truc non mais franchement peut-être
que oui mais Jean-Michel tu dis oui tu
peux tester
aussi mais rayon tu avais pas un
problème juridique cet été j'étais au
sport
moi moi j'étais au sport moi non il
avait un problème J donc il aurait pu
tester l'application comment tu sais toi
parce que mais si il se confie on en a
parlé l'autre fois on en a parlé à
l'autre émission d'avant tu étais
là c'est moi verau ents non prendre un
ver tous les deux un ver
d'tique au de fin d'année de Guillaume
la société de Guillaume faire un ver
d'eau à B il m'a dit parce que c'est
gratuit vous êtes venu pour parler de
rmon ou pour parler comme personne n'a
bossé j'essaie de meubler
alors par sujet il y en a pas un qui l'
t tous les gens qui viennent s'asseoir
ici depis le professeur raou il vous
défon c'est la jurisprudence raou je
vous dis on sait ce qu'il y a dans cette
application pe de quoi vous avez peur
avec cette ah bon j'adore parce que lui
il est incroyable je l'adore lui c'est
le seul mec qui peut parler de quelque
chose qu'il a pas vu mais en disant
voilà avec un incroyable C parce que
j'ai lu des papiers
alerté les journalist l'ont
fait je l'ai pas testé à
[Rires]
travers
j'aiococ fais unemission de
fairequ ça s'appelle une faute
professionnelle fais pas deux
fois une fois une fois Jama vu ça jamais
vu ça j'ai jamais vu ça ça fait 11 ans
que je suis là j'ai jamais vu il mer
comme fum mais alors toi
alors c'est toi qui devais travailler
sur ce dossier dis pas et toi qu'est-ce
que tu fais tu branles rien tu Dr c'est
ça j'étais pas censé bosser sur ce
dossier po c'est bon non mais c'est vrai
le gars vient pour draguer po SC
maintenant non mais il a le
se attaqu les autres c'est toi qui deis
trer sur il a changé depuis qu'il Dr pa
SC voabulaire non tu me fais marer
aller pas y aller non pas du tout pas du
tout alors c'est quoi le problème bah le
problème c'est pour les justiciables
parce que les plus démunis j'ai par
parler clairement par que moi déjà le
problème c'est pour les gens les gens
ceux qui vont en patir son bon alors je
commencer un les avocats les avocats on
va leur dire vous prenez trop d'argent
les revenus des avocats on va dire
médian donc ceux qui ont 50 % en plus 50
% en moins c'est 46000 € brut donc il y
a des avocats qui crèvent la dalle et de
l'autre côté il y a des avocats qui ont
énormément quand on n' pas d'argent on
ne dépense pas 69 € pour de
l'intelligence artificielle quand vous
avez une femme batue qui est acculée qui
est au bout est-ce qu'elle a envie
d'entendre la voix de Syrie qui lui dit
sans aucune humanité aucune empathie
voilà la règle de droit
mais pas du
tout
chèmis G sur pour çaè
vois son très des G qui sont trèsqu qui
sont capable grâce à ça de pou se
défendre cons
j
consult consultation
grat peux comprendre que toi en
tantavocate ça t'emble pas mais il y a
des gens qui la téléchar ça
marche des erreurs par ailleurs des
témoignages effectivement ils ont
l'intelligence artificielle a donné au
plignants des lois qui
étaient tout bidon person qui
fait
et parfois mieux vaut se débrouiller
soi-même que d'avoir un mauvais avocat
aussi il y a quand même avocat qui sont
vous app Clara pard non mais je peux je
peux mappeler
[Musique]
claraaa non c'est juste qu' il y a un an
quand on a tous appris l'arrivée de
l'intelligence artificielle je pense que
les gens n'ont pas bien compris on est
passé dans un autre monde tout va
évoluer comme ça nos présences
télévisuelles les textes les études ard
des
chronurs et en réalité il va falloir
qu'on se demande quelle place on
a
aintellig a raison quand on a vu
l'intelligence artificielle AR moi la
première chose que je me suis dit me
suis j'ai raté l'intelligence Rai pas
l'intelligence
artificielle mais pardona mais qu'est-ce
que ça a concrètement changé depuis un
an à ta vie l'intelligence artificielle
ou ça changé énormément la vie des gens
ta vie bien nous par exemple avec mon
toutes les descriptions de produits sont
faites par lia je suis en
trainuleu c'est qui c'est Michel ou
c'est le professeur non je voulais
savoir par exemple je suis en train de
de parler avec un créatif qui se demande
ce que vont devenir les personnalités
dans 5 dans 10 ans parce qu'en réalité
la voix d' Angel par exemple est déjà
sur des chansons qu'elle n'a pas chanté
avec lia on peut fabriquer des voix donc
quelle est la à ça et je pense que ça
peut être des avatars aussi Onira jamais
voir un avatar dans un
spectacle existe déjà avec des
hologrammes ché en fait en fait je viens
de me rendre compte d'un truc c'est que
ce sujet je m'en tape total donc Sarah
merci d'être venue chéri non mais tu
restes un peu ouais mais franchement je
m'en ta total dans un instant